hey guys happy holidays do you like my
background you may notice it's not white
well it can be white but i got myself a
green screen so now i'm going to
i don't know probably still use my white
wall anyway i'm super excited because
i've never actually put up a christmas
tree by myself in my own place because
i'm usually too lazy and i'm still too
lazy and if you watch this time lapse
you'll still see that i really didn't
put it up at all ryan kind of did it all
i was getting all these comments about
you guys yelling at me because i didn't
get a real tree like a real tr well i'm
so so sorry but it was funny as you guys
were acting like i was trying to hide it
i clearly took this tree out of a box i
ordered it on amazon it came with the
lights already on it so basically all we
had to do was stack it together and plug
it in and guess what merry freaking
christmas here's our christmas tree
now the best part about this tree is
i asked you guys in my vlogmas video
which is vlog every day until christmas
you can check that out on my other scene
channel is you guys told me to go to
target to get some ornaments so
naturally i pretty much do whatever you
guys tell me to do except get a real
tree because i ain't got time for that
so i went to get the ornaments and while
i was there not only did i see that they
had a cheetah onesie he's a cheetah
onesie
oh god in a zebra oh my goodness but
they had star wars ornaments so i was so
excited so i got them and i i brought
them home and i put them on the tree and
they look
just they look beautiful
now my question to you guys is what does
your christmas tree look like go film a
video of you and your christmas tree and
bonus points for dancing and if you
don't actually have a christmas tree
because you don't celebrate christmas uh
just go find a tree and dance in front
of it and be taking a bunch of those
videos and kind of mashing them all
together and making a little music video
thank you guys for watching don't forget
to subscribe to this channel so you guys
will know when i post new videos and i
also have a bunch of other channels
um so here they are so go check those
out and i will see you guys when i post
another video